so what I wanted to do here is have a
discussion on the origin of Barry Allen
the flash from the new 52 and what I'm
hoping is that at the end of this video
you'll have a good understanding of his
origin story as well as why he was
rebooted for the new 52
so the origin for Barry Allen comes in
Secret Origins issue number seven from
2014 and the flash issue number zero as
part of DC zero month in September of
2012 the flash number zero was one of a
series of stories which celebrated the
one-year anniversary of the new 52
launched and focused entirely on the
origins of DC's characters and teams and
conversely Secret Origins provides us
with an updated story for Barry Allen
while simultaneously drawing on elements
from the origin and flash issue number
zero written in drawn by Brian Brooke a
Leto and Frances mana pool in a 2012
interview with Digital Spy
we're both bucola to a mana pool
recognized that wally west had been the
flash for the last 26 years the
editorial mandate as it had been handed
down required that with the new 52
reboot Barry Allen would be designated
as the flash for the series going
forward and to break away and provide a
little background here in 1985 the
crisis on Infinite Earths sought to take
what was a confusing and contradictory
continuity they can diss it down into
something new and manageable as a way to
draw in new readers with Barry Allen
having been established as a flash in
1956 with DC showcase issue number four
going into the crisis on Infinite Earths
DC Mutis character as a remnant of an
older time because readers were looking
for fresh faces as well as fresh stories
DC killed Barry Allen off and replaced
him with his nephew Wally West and so
from 1985 up until 2009 Wally had been
the only version of the flash that the
current generation of readers grew up
with however in a 2011 interview with
Newsarama
Geoff Johns had stated that were plans
to reboot the DC continuity extended as
early as 2007 the decision to reboot
came to fruition during 2010 where
meetings were held determining how the
reboot would be initiated and what
direction that continuity would follow
afterwards while I haven't been able to
pinpoint any information indicating why
Barry Allen was chosen to reboot the
continuity at the direction of DC
editorial Geoff Johns launched the 2009
flash rebirth event which serves the
purpose of Rick counting or modifying
the history of the flash mythos and two
notable ways the Speed Force and the
death of Barry's mother
and with a standard explanation of the
speedforce came in impulse issue number
66 and 2000 with it being defined as the
source of the speedsters power as well
as a sort of afterlife where speedsters
go when they die under Geoff Johns the
concept was remodeled entirely what
we're told is that from the time he
became the flash every time Barry Allen
used his powers and ran at SuperSpeed
the energy he let off began to collect
itself into a massive form of power that
existed outside the multiverse and so
over the twenty nine year history of
Barry Allen acting as the flash between
his introduction in 1956 and the crisis
on Infinite Earths of 1985 Barry
constantly added more and more energy to
the Speed Force until it reached a
critical mass of sorts and then it
became a source of power for every
speedster that has ever existed across
DC's multiversal continuity and contain
all knowledge of all those continuities
and furthermore when Barry Allen had
died in 1985 during the crisis on
Infinite Earths event Geoff Johns
revealed the Barry Allen had actually
joined with the Speed Force and using
this retcon was able to restore him to
the DC continuity now regarding his
mother where Barry's initial history had
him growing up in Fall Ville Iowa with
both parents and then moving to Central
City where he eventually became the
flash after being exposed to chemicals
while being electrocuted under Geoff
Johns a history was partially retcon and
a new narrative was created and the
original story from flash vol 2 issues
number 74 through 79 eobard thawne was
actually a fan of Barry Allen from the
25th century obsessed with meeting his
idol he went as far as to have his face
surgically modified in order to actually
look like Barry Allen replicating the
electrochemical bath that gave Barry his
powers he jumped into the timestream two
huge held to the past but arrived after
the crisis on Infinite Earths with his
Monda in a daze due to the unexpected
shock of traveling through time he
visited the Museum of Barry Allen and
discovered that he was destined to
become the reverse-flash the most
dangerous enemy of Barry's coming
completely unhinged his mind snapped and
as a result he stepped into the villa
that he was completely meant to be now
under Geoff Johns the schemes of the
reverse-flash led him to traveling into
the past and instigating a series of
attacks on Barry including killing his
dog engineering the scenario that led
him to getting his powers and killing
his mother and so using this as a
jumping-off point
DC then turned around
and launch the 2011 flashpoint event
which centered on Barry Allen's attempt
to stop eobard thawne and save his
mother and so while his actions would
have disastrous consequences in that
noir Allen survival created an alternate
reality where Barry Allen never became
the flash Bruce Wayne died is said of
his parents Superman had been discovered
and imprisoned by the government as a
child and Wonder Woman's Amazon's were
at war with Aquaman's Atlanteans Barry
Allen's attempts to set things right by
allowing his mother to die provided DC
with the ability to start things fresh
by canceling out all of the past
continuity for the flash series and so
with bucola dough and mana pool heading
up the new 52 flash with issue number 1
their task became clear right Barry
Allen in a way that could intrigue new
readers but also ensure older readers
stayed onboard
so the origin of Barry Allen picks up by
establishing that like the rest of DC is
line up in the new 52 the super-powered
beings had only appeared within the last
five years while talking to his father
in prison we learned that every year on
the anniversary of his mother's death
Barry comes to the prison to meet with
his father providing us with a backstory
we learned that the relationship between
Barry and his mother Nora was a
significant aspect of his life in that
while she babied him a bit she was also
a source of confidence for him on the
day his mother dies Barry is heading to
school for field day and while he
expresses nervousness over his ability
to succeed in the various challenges his
mother assures him that he'll be fine
following the conclusion of the school
day and arriving back home
Barry finds his mother dead and his
father covered in blood urging his son
not to look because of the traumatic
experience it would cause Barry tells us
that his memory actually blacks out
between the time he found his mother
dead and the time his father was
arrested by the police
as part of his inner narrative were
informed that according to the police
the murder of Nora Allen was an
open-and-shut case and that his father
Henry Allen had been found at the scene
of the crime covered in his wife's blood
and there was no evidence that a
perpetrator had entered the house prior
to Henry's arrival obsessed with proving
his father's innocence and tracking down
his mother's killer Barry takes to
learning everything he can about
forensics unfolding elements of his
origin story from 1956 into this origin
DC establishes that Barry has trouble
with time management but ultimately
graduates from college in addition were
told that we're Noir Allen's death
inspired Barry to get involved in
forensics by the time he graduated his
desire had transcended to ensuring that
other families don't experience the same
kind of pain as himself continuing the
trend of taking aspects from Barry
Allen's origin in 1956 and folding them
into this story were shown that while
working for the police force in the
forensics lab and analyzing clues from
the crime scene of his mother's death a
lightning bolt strikes his shelf behind
Barry and douses hemming chemicals after
spending time in a hospital the doctor
and attending informs buried that where
he initially had shown up with
electrical and chemical burns his
injuries had healed and rapid time
because he had enter to the hospital of
his own accord and the doctor saw no
reason to keep him there Barry's allowed
to leave at which point he comes to the
realization that he has to
speed running to various locations
including India Barry comments that his
experience in losing his mother and
father at such a young age required him
to grow up extremely fast as a result he
learned that where life would tend to
throw curve balls the measure of a man
is the decision he makes and the impact
that he has on the world around him
deciding that his abilities are a gift
he begins a process of creating a
costume for himself as he tells us we're
police officers have uniforms to
establish themselves in a position of
authority the purpose of the flash
uniform is to establish his role as a
superhero seeking to ensure the safety
of central city and its occupants giving
us a sort of montage in the form of his
battles with Captain Cold mirror master
and Grodd Barry Allen tells us that his
experiences in life the road that he's
taken has provided him with the
opportunity to ensure that other
families in Central City don't have to
experience the same kind of loss he did
but as the origin story begins to come
to a close he also states that noir
Allen's death is still a focal point of
his character and as much of a driving
force behind his actions as a safety of
the city with that being said we're
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end I hope you guys enjoyed it and I
will catch you guys later peace